ビーフ
皆さん
最近一番ワクワクドキドキしたのっていつですか
子供の頃っていつもワクワクドキドキしていました
高い滑り台に登って勇気を出しておいた時
自転車を合意で補助人が初めてとれたとき
ただそんな気持ちもを唱えなるにつれて
忘れていてしまいます
私は今ワークショップデザイナーとして大人も子どももワクワクできる
そんな場を作っています
今日は私が実践しているワクワクドキドキできる
そんな3つの実践について話をしたいと思います
一つ目
それは遊ぶこと
少し昔のことを思い出してほしいんですが
そう小学生の頃
幼稚園や
保育園の頃
何か習い事ってしてました
水泳
サッカー
ピアノや書道
英会話や学習塾
私はどれも興味を示さなかったんです
時間があれば鬼ごっこしたり大根月したり
そんなことばかりしてる小学生でした
ただ一つだけ興味を持ったものがあります
コンピューターです
windows 95が発売されて1年ご
小学校4年生の頃です
新聞に偶然朝待っていたパソコンスクールのチラシがきっかけです
今だったらプログラミング学習
web デザイン
ただ当時の私がハマったのはタイピングソフトと oa化技でした
マジックフライトというタイピングソフトがありました
魔女を岸まで届ける
正しいキーボード打てばコードが上がり
入力が遅かったり間違ったりするとコードが落ちる
今思えば単純なゲームなんです
ただその時子先生から
終えこの作例作ったら魔女のゲームやっていいぞ
誰よりも早く作ったんです
遊んでいくうちに私はそのソフトが表計算ソフトになり
データベースソフトになり気付けば
付け歯
児童に作業をするマクロを組めるようにもなってました
最初はただただ遊んでいただけなんです
すると生徒からも友達からも
コンピューターに付いたらも時に行こうそんな風に言われていました
そのうちそれが喜びになり教えることが楽しくなったんです
私は今専門学校で情報の教員としてコンピューターや
プログラムについて教えています
そう
遊ぶことを目いっぱい遊ぶこと
わくわくするためには遊ぶことが大事なんです
ただそれは誰かに与えられたルールじゃないんです
ましてやお金をたくさんつぎ込めばレベルアップる
するそんなゲームでもないんですそ自分でルールを作って自分で遊ぶこと
皆さん最近遊んでます
わくわくする二つ目
それは新しい環境に
飛び出すこと
大学院に進学して私は e ラーニングの制作や
学習におけるモチベーションについて研究していました
その傍ら高校で情報の教員として宣誓をしていました
その頃はどうすれば生徒が事業に興味を持ってくれるかそんなことばかり考えて
授業教材を考えてました
初めての期末試験
どうすれば生徒が興味を持ってくれるか
どうすれば生徒の知識が図れて生徒が自分自身の考えて問題を解いてくれるかそんな事
を考え
試験の半分以上を記述式にしました
しかし
それが失敗でした
生徒全然変えてくれないんです
書いていても自分の言葉じゃ全然ない
平均点もすごいひどかった
初めて持った受け持った生徒の数は280人
採点するだけでも2週間もかかったんです
その次の期末試験では
マークシートにしました
なんと282の祭典が5分で終わったんです
5分ですよ
この1年は自分の理想とするものそしてその現実のギャップをとても感じた1年でした
その後名古屋に移り専門学校の教員として教えている間もどうすれば学生がワクワク
ドキドキしてくれるかそんなことばかり考え実践していました
そこで1冊の論文と出会います
そこにはプログラミング学習について大学で教えている
がっ実践研究実践において書かれていました
そこには
スクラッチというプログラミングツールを使い学生同士が学び合っている姿でした
授業後には学生が後輩や外の学校の子供たちにプログラミングを教えていたんです
スクラッチ
mit が開発したプログラミング環境です
プログラミングというと凄い難しいイメージ文法を覚えないと作ることができません
ただスクラッチは
色の色や形を見るだけでそれを組み合わせるだけで自分のキャラクターを動かしたり
すぐにその反応を見ることができたんです
そう子供の時ブロックでお城やロボットをつくったかなよ
ワークショップ
学校の勉強といえば
大きな机に同じ方向にスが向いていて先生がその一つ高いところからノートを書いてあ
万象を書いて私たちがそれをノートに取る
そんな学びのものをワークショップは壊してくれました
ワークショップの学びはひとりではなく共同体
知識を習得するのを主な目的たせず自分たちで課題を決め
自分たちで納得社会に向かっていく
そうだ
自分がありタイのワークショップなんだ
そう強く思ってからはワークショップを実践している人
研究知る人にすぐにでも会いたいと思ったんです
そこで
一人の先生と出会えます
アメリカのセサミストリートについて研究をし日本では a nhk のおかあさんと
いっしょの制作に携わった
同志社女子大学上田信行先生です
学習環境デザインをテーマにさまざまなワークショップをされている方でした
上田先生が大阪で公演するとき
仕事の勇気を取ってすぐに迎えました
ただそこでもびっくりなんですびっくりの連続
先生はステージ上がっているとギターを持ってるんですよ
祈祷もできない歌を歌いだすんですそしてみんなに言うんです
さあたって一緒に歌いましょう一緒に楽器を作って演奏しましょうと言うんです
もう数号エネルギーのある人だなと思いました
それから私は上田先生のワークショップにたくさん参加しました
そして私はもっとこれワークショップについて実践的理論的に学びたいと思いました
その一年後
東京にある青山学院大学
ワークショップデザイナー育成プログラムというものを受講してました
月曜日から金曜日までナグアの専門学校で先生をしながら
金曜日の授業が終わったらそのままの格好で深夜バスに乗り込むです
週末は学生をして
そしてまた終わったら深夜バスに乗ってまたな具合に戻って宣誓をする
そんな事を繰り返しました
ただ
ここであった
一緒に学んでいるみんなとアイディアをぶつけ合ったり
そして税をからワークショップをつくっていく作業
これはホントわくわくドキドキしたんです
二つ目のキーワードは
大
ワクワクドキドキしてる人そんな人や花ところに飛び込んでほしいんです
そう今だったら
そうだあテレックス hia の上 naver に飛び込んでみるとか
もし今ワクワクドキドキしてない人
それもしかしたら環境の所為かも知れません
新しいそういうバリン自らちょっと飛び込んでみたらどうですか何か見つかるかもしれ
ません
最後に3つ目
それは表現してみることです伝えてみること
ワークショップやプログラミングツールについてたくさんした私は自分でも場を持ち
たいと思ったんです
ただ最初から何でもできたわけでありません
一参加者としてその場に参加し運営者の方に
今回受けたものを私も行ってもいいですか一つずつお願いをしてみようみまねで始めた
んです
一番最初にあったワークショップ
モーションセンサーを使った身体の動きに反応する作品を作るワークショップです
参加者は
先輩のおこさにつ参加してもらい
小学校3年生の友達も3人制て来てもらいトータル4目
小さなワークショップです
スクラッチの操作について簡単に確認した後は
子どもたちにオリジナル作品を作ってもらいました
テーマは動物そう世界に一つだけその子だけの動物園をつくってワークショップです
ただ
最初ということもありとても試行錯誤
どうなるかわからないのが進めていきました
ただ
そこでの子供たちの笑顔どうぞ
すごい可愛いですよね
これが忘れられなかったそれが第1回目のワークショップでした
あと私はレゴがすごい好きな子供だったんです
だからコンピュータを使わないアンプラグドな授業ができないかと
学生と相談してました
そのブロックを積み上げて何かできないか
私は学生とレシピと言われる支持票を作ったんです
その支持票通り学生たちがブロックを組み立てていくと何か出来上がっていくんです
これによってコンピューターの0と1の仕組みはアルゴル水について学んでいったん
です
学生は自分たちで作ったもの学んだものを自然とスマートフォンで撮って写真を撮るん
ですそう
学生たちが自然と学んだアウトプットを自分たちでシェアし始めたんです
なかなかないですよねこんなこと
最近では
10年以上子どもたちの創造や表現力のばそれをキーワードに
ワークショップやイベントをしている npo 法人 canvas と協力のもと
プログラミングを通じた学びの場プログラミング education ギャザリング
ペグ札幌開催しました
2日間で100に近い参加者でした
私はそこで
led の点灯と
その光を検知する光センサーを制御し
子どもたちが画面上で作った作品をつなげる
ピタゴラ装置を作るワークショップを開催しました
プログラミングといえば一つの画面にこう方々するイメージありますよね
ただピタゴラ装置を作るこのワークショップは都内同士協力し合わないとうまく動か
ないんです
そ自然と隣同士が話し合って相談して作っていくんです
そして大きな作品
できたら今度どうしますみなさん
そう
自信を持ってできるものがあったらこの誰かに自慢したくなりますよね
次は発表する時間をとったんです
ございません
さあ自分たちの
作品が動いていきます隣の友達から光を検知したら自分の作品が動き出す
動いたら今度は次のお友達次の友達に動いていくんです
次は最後の友達の場
いやぁぁぁあああああああああ
どうです子供達のわくわくドキドキしたり姿
ここにありますよね
3つめのキーは
何か物を作ったり
何かこう自分ので作ったものが目の前でいただき
そう今度はそれを誰かに見せてほしいんです
プログラミング
ものづくりが好きな人
何か
好きなものをどんどん作ってくださいそしてそれを誰かに見せてあげてほしいんです
一人で本を読むのが好きな人
感想を web 上に公開してみたらどうですか
絵が好きな人
学生なら
ルーズリーフに
グラフィックの会でノートを取ってみて友達見せてみたらどうですか
今まで退屈だった授業が少しワクワクするかもしれません
何が自分の作ったものを誰かに見せること
ステージに立って表現すること
それは少し勇気のいることかもしれません
ただそれ以上にワクワクドキドキするんです
そうこのてレックスのステージの良い
プレイ
遊ぶことを目いっぱい遊ぶこと
大
熱量のある人のところに飛び込んでみること
パフォーム
ステージに立って表現すること
今は
世界中の素晴らしいアイディアや学校の授業は
インターネットで無料で学ぶことができます
これからどんどんどんどんインターネットが進んでいけば何でもネット上でできるよう
になります
ただその時に大切なのはワクワクドキドキする心
そう
学ぶことが楽しいと思えることなんです
頭の良し悪しが全てじゃない
もし
学びたいことが決まってないあなた
大丈夫
必ず見つかります
だからもっと遊んで
飛び込んで表現してみてほしいんです
そしてもしよかったら
あなたの近くの周りの人その人をワクワクドキドキできる
そんなプロジェクトを今日からはじめてみませんか
最後に
先ほど紹介した上田信行先生の言葉を紹介して終わりたいと思います
楽しく学ぶということではない
楽しいことの中に
学び溢れてるんだ
ありがとうございます